what the hell was that
you heard about the cave-in yeah i'm
putting together a rescue mission
we have 26 trapped miners who are
running out of air i need 300 feet of
pipe delivered up there
in under 30 hours can you make it happen
says you had experience on the ice
rodent yep
he's the mechanic one of the best
meet jesus give me 50 bucks one of my
drivers just became available
what's it for bail uh yeah what told you
this wasn't gonna be easy
i'm in
the only way up there is crossing the
ice roads but that lake has been falling
for five weeks now
if they are able to accomplish this we
will be exposed
so the question is time
we've been sabotaged
my brother isn't that mine this is
personal
now i'm angry
what the hell was that
sweet jesus that ain't good spreading
out
it's gonna keep cracking for two maybe
three thousand meters
we're gonna have to run tight together
go
coming loose and you're all going in
deserve time
we're coming just hang on
you